Abdell, how you doing?
>> How's it going, man?
>> Pretty good. Happy
>> birthday.
>> Thank you.
>> First of all,
>> of course. So, obviously I'm a Muslim,
you know, speaking to a Christian. So,
yeah. Uh, my question to you is what is
what are the things or one thing that is
preventing you from becoming Muslim now?
And I'll answer.
>> All right. The biggest thing that's
preventing me from becoming Muslim is
the uh inconsistency it has when it
comes to the previous prophets. So uh it
says for example that we we'll be able
to find Muhammad mentioned in the Torah
and Gospel and he's nowhere to be found.
And so that's huge for me as a Bible
believer.
>> So you say there's inconsistencies with
Prophet Muhammad being mentioned in
other scriptures just like the Bible and
Torah.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I mean, but but there's verses in
the Bible that quotes a prophecy made by
Jesus, you know, made by God to Jesus
that prophet Muhammad will appear in the
future, just like the Torah, you know,
like Muhammad in in Torah. And then the
Bible,
>> there's there's there's nothing there's
nothing in the gospel where Jesus talks
about the coming of Muhammad. And
there's nothing in the Torah either.
>> What about the belief system we have?
What is contradicting about us believing
in just one Almighty? Well, there's a
lot of religions that believe in one
Almighty. And so believing in one
almighty God is not what makes you right
with the true God because you can
believe in one God but have that a false
idea of who God is. You know, you can
have a false god. Uh so you have to
believe in the true one almighty God.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Actually actually we believe
in the same God but you guys refer God
as father.
>> Pray to God is the same God Muslims
believe in actually. See the only
difference between us is the trinity.
That's what's stopping us.
>> If even even if even if we so if we if
the thing that's stopping us is the
trinity then you don't believe in the
same God because God in the Bible is
triune. Obviously the God in Islam is
not right. And then two even if we talk
about just the person of the father
you're you're trying to say that who we
relate the who we say the father is.
You're saying that that's connected with
who Allah is. But that's not true
because you don't believe that Allah is
the father. Like Allah says, "No, in no
way is he a father."
>> I mean, that's just a reference. You
know what I'm saying? Is it is he
biologically a father or metaphorically
speaking?
>> He's he's a father literally like truly
like cuz Jesus is his begotten son. So
Jesus is begotten from his essence. And
then you have he has spiritual children
that he adopts like believers,
Christians who come to the faith in the
Messiah. He adopts them as his children.
Israel, you know, they're his children
as well that he birthed as a nation. And
so, see, he has many he has children in
many ways, but Allah doesn't have
children in any way.
>> Okay? I mean, we just refer to them as
servants. And I'm sure you read the
Quran and you've seen that Adam is
actually has the same example of Jesus
because he is born without a father and
a mother.
>> Adam wasn't born
>> actually special if you think about it.
>> No, Adam wasn't Adam wasn't born. He was
created.
>> He was created exactly just like Jesus
was created. Everybody was created. not
Jesus. Even in both of our books, it it
talks about how Jesus is the the word of
God, right? And
>> of course, he is the word of God. And
>> that means no, Muhammad is not the word
of God, brother.
>> Makes me say that. How how listen do you
know how we know that Muhammad is the
word of God? Because how do we know
Jesus existed? It came from the Quran,
from the Bible.
>> It didn't come from the Quran.
>> Yes. Jesus says that we believe he's a
prophet. You you know you know but Jesus
well listen listen Jesus being a prophet
existed he was a prophet long before the
Quran came right
>> okay just like Abraham was a long
>> so so these exactly so these prophets
their their prophethood and who they are
is not dependent on what the Quran says
they they were who they were before the
Quran came so the Quran doesn't
determine their existence and how they
existed right
>> basically as you know yeah as you know
you know the Quran is a fine final
testament. So, it's the final round of
everything.
>> I I disagree. The reason like it's like
like I said, the the reason why I
disagree is because it's not consistent
with what they taught. It's telling us
that they taught things that they
actually didn't. It's saying that mo
Jesus and the Torah and other scriptures
talk about Muhammad and the Quran when
they don't. That's a huge blunder. If it
look, if if they never spoke about
Muhammad and didn't foretell his coming,
then the Quran is making a false claim
and can't possibly be the word of God.
>> Well, I don't know on the top of my head
the verse exactly that says Jesus
speaking about the prophecy that is
coming about Muhammad coming in the
future, but there is it is in the Bible.
But
>> how do you how do you know it's in the
Bible if you don't if you don't know?
>> There is a verse. There's a verse. I
mean, you can pull it out,
>> brother. There there's there's no verse
where Jesus talks about Muhammad, bro.
None. Do you want to hear
>> Do you do you hear one of Do you hear
one of what they quote when they think
that it's about Muhammad? You want to
hear that?
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay. So, this is where Muslims would
would quote when they think that it's
about it's about Muhammad. It's John 14
verse 16 to 17 where it talks about
where Jesus says that another comforter
is going to come. Okay.
>> Exactly. Yes. Exactly. Another
comforter. Yep.
>> All right. You got it, man.
>> So, now watch watch what it says here
and you tell me if this sounds like
Muhammad to you. Now, I I I trust that
you're going to be honest with me.
>> Of course, man.
>> You sound like an honest guy. So, just
this ad to go off. Okay, there we go.
All right. So, this what it says. Okay.
It says, uh, "If you love me, you will
keep my commandments, and I will ask the
Father, and he will give you another
comforter to be with you forever." even
the Spirit of truth whom the world
cannot receive because it neither sees
him nor knows him but you know him for
he dwells with you and will be in you.
So Jesus is talking to his disciples
here. The immediate context he's talking
to his disciples and he's telling the
disciples. He's saying I'm about to go
away. But when I go away, I will ask the
father and he'll send you another
comforter. Right.
>> So the comforter is coming to the
disciples and he's going to be with them
forever. Okay.
>> Cool.
>> Does that sound like Muhammad?
>> If he's referring to a comforter, yes,
because he's the last messenger of all
mankind. So you believe that Muhammad
came to the disciples of Jesus in the
first century?
>> I mean uh he came 600 years after. We
all know that.
>> So this J Jesus says the comforter is
going to come to his disciples not 600
years later.
>> Well if he listen so that's the thing
you realize that also in the Bible
there's a lot of contradictory stuff.
>> Oh come on brother. You said this was
it. You said this was it. You said yeah
this is it.
>> No but this is actually Muhammad. But
even in the in the Quran, man, even
Jesus in the Quran, right? It says that
he spoke about
>> I know that's what I'm talking about. It
says Jesus mentioned a messenger named
Ahmed to come after him. My problem is
is that when I look at what Jesus said,
he never says that. He never mentions
nobody named Ahmed coming after him. He
doesn't mention any human prophet coming
after him. What he talks about is a
spirit who the father he and the father
will send who's going to come to the
disciples and then to the rest of those
who will believe after them and will
indwell them empower them guide them
then and now not 600 years later. You
get my point? I don't come to I
understand. I understand completely. But
at the same time, bro, like you see the
scientific evidence that is in the Quran
that even a man in the wizard would
never know about, would never know
about. There's so much, you know, you
you read the Quran. I'm sure you are
intellectual about that.
>> What about the scientific inaccuracies
that he gets?
>> Like what?
>> So like he he says that the earth was
created before the heavens. The earth
was created in I think two days and then
the heavens were created in four days or
something like that. What do you mean?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So he said well that the
earth was created in in four days total
and the and then the heavens were
created in two days.
>> And so he he create he created and
finished the earth first
>> and then made the heavens which is
scientifically impossible.
>> How is that scient No. How is that
scientifically impossible? Because
according to science, the universe or
the heavens was created before the
earth. That's that's time space matter.
So that has to be first. So that when
you create the earth, you have a time
and a space to put the earth. Without
the the without the heavens or the
universe, you don't have a place to put
the earth. And that would also make the
earth eternal because it would be
without time. You know what I'm saying?
>> Well, I get what you're saying, but
that's just whatever. That's how God
created the earth and the heavens. But
listen,
>> but that's but that's that's scient
Look, I know from the Quran standpoint,
that's how he created it. But
scientifically, that's impossible. Like
that's a scientifically that's
scientifically false.
>> I need to look into that. I've never
heard about scientifically it's
impossible that the earth comes first
before the heavens. I've never seen that
chronological order even being spoken
about. So I don't know. Like so so so
you you you know scientifically the
universe is older than the earth, right?
>> Yeah. I mean the big thing, right?
>> Yes. Exactly. And so the universe is
older than the earth, but the Quran puts
the earth before the universe.
>> It it puts in in you mean in context
like the words earth. It didn't say did
it say earth first?
>> Yes. It it creates the earth first. Like
it create look it it goes let me let me
read it to you. So this is uh we'll find
this in like in chapter 41 starting at
verse 9 to 12 and this is what it says
and even like I'm I'm not making this up
like if you read like I like the tapsier
they have the same conclusion that the
earth was created first from these
verses right so it says say do you
indeed believe in he who created the
earth in two days and attribute to him
equals that is the lord of the worlds
right so he created the earth in two
days verse 10 and He placed on the earth
firmly set mountains over its surface
and he blessed it and determined therein
its sustenance in four days without
distinction for of those for those who
ask. So um depending on how you
interpret this whether this is six days
or maybe it's a it's like a total of
four days I don't that doesn't matter.
>> All right so let's let's just go yeah
let's go with that it's a total of four
days that um he created the earth like
he created the earth and finished the
earth in a total of four days. Okay. So
the earth is finished now. Right. Now
watch what happens. So verse 11 it says
then right then he rose towards the
heaven while it was smoke. Right? So the
heaven wasn't anything yet. It was just
smoke at this point. And I says that
this smoke came from the earth. Like
when Allah created the earth and from
the heat and everything that he was
making it with, smoke rose up from the
earth and and that's what that was.
That's what says. Um
>> I mean yeah anyways yeah I see I see
nothing wrong in that. I mean whatever
you just said whatever you read I mean
that makes sense.
>> No problem.
>> Okay. So so he rose towards the heaven
while it was smoke and said to it and to
the earth come willingly or by
compulsion. They said we have come
willingly. So the earth is already
finished. The heaven isn't made yet.
It's just smoke. And he calls to them,
right? And then verse 12 is what we get.
He says, "Then he completed them as
seven heavens within two days and
decorated in each, I'm sorry, inspired
each heaven its command. And we adorned
the lowest heaven with stars, right?
With stars and as protection. That is
the determination of the exalted in uh
in might and the knowing. So the heaven,
the heavens, even the lowest heaven that
we see, right? Space, when we look out
in the night sky, the lowest heaven,
that's ours. Space, the stars, all of
that came after the earth was created,
which is scientifically false.
>> Listen, okay, it could be whatever
scientifically you think. Maybe at the
end of the day, God beats science. We
all know that. You believe in that,
right? Whatever.
>> Remember, you appealed to this. You you
appealed and said that Muhammad gets
science scientific accuracies correct
that which shows that he's a true
prophet and the Quran is true. So that
would mean that if he gets scientific
inaccuracies then the Quran is false
that he's a false prophet.
>> Yeah. But there's no inaccuracy
how God created. I know he showed me but
that's just how God created it. About
science scientists can yap all day long.
You know what I'm saying? They can be
saying oh. So, do you see how do you see
how your first standard doesn't work?
Because at first you said you're you
were appealing to science as a way to
prove Islam true, but now you're saying
forget science once it shows the Quran
is false.
>> But the go but okay so when I said that
science proves Islam is true by making
Prophet Muhammad the true prophet. It's
because there's a lot of verses. For
example, the oceans of the Pacific or
Atlantic, I forgot exactly. They don't
mix, right,
>> brother? You're you're missing my point.
You're missing my point. I'm I I can
grant you, let's say, cuz I I don't
agree. But let me say I grant you for
the sake of argument that Muhammad got
some things scientifically true, right?
He got some scientific accuracies within
the Quran. And you're saying that these
scientific accuracies
show that Muhammad is a true prophet
because he got some things
scientifically correct. So that means
that if he gets things scientifically
wrong, then he's a false prophet. And
that's what we just saw that he got
something scientifically wrong. He said
the earth was created before the
universe.
>> Yeah. But the thing is, you can you can
say how heavens got to be first and then
you got to say earth got to be second,
but you don't know if that's actually
true. You can't even prove it.
>> You're missing it again.
>> According to science, according to
science, it is objectively factual that
the universe came before the earth.
That's a scientific fact.
>> The verse. Okay. Okay. I can say one
thing. When you read the Quran verse,
right? It said it put earth but it never
said God created earth first then he
just said God created earth in two days
>> so right so when when when you say and
then what does the word then mean
>> and then is when uh
>> something comes next right
>> 100% yeah but at the same time
>> so he created the earth he created the
earth when
>> look he doesn't have to say he I created
the earth first all he has to say is the
earth was created in four days. Then,
>> okay,
>> the heavens were made. That word then
shows a sequence of time. First it was
the earth, then it was the heavens.
>> Okay, cool, man. I I don't want to like
elaborate more because, you know, I'm
not scientifically like very
knowledgeable about the facts, but I
just know for a fact, listen, at the end
of the day, the the truth will always
prevail. We all believe in one God, and
we believe in all of his prophets.
>> That's not enough. You don't you don't
believe in the true God yet, nor do you
believe in his prophets.
>> True God.
>> But what do you think our God is? What
do you think?
>> I think that I think that the God of
Islam is a false god. Is a false god.
>> Why is he a false god?
>> Because he because he is not the God of
the of Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob. The
God that Jesus preached about,
>> that Moses preached about, that all the
other prophets preached about, this God
does not match his qualities, his
characteristics, nothing. So
>> I think that Okay, what is it? For
example, yeah, for example, here's a big
thing.
>> Allah says in the Quran that he does not
begget, nor is he begotten, right? And
he says he doesn't have a son in any
way, shape, or form. That's a big huge
thing. It's a big no no. Matter of fact,
Allah says in chapter 19, verse 89 and
91 and 90 that it is an atrocious thing
to attribute to Allah a son
>> 100%. What is wrong with that? Of
course, because God does not be fit. I
got you.
>> Actually about it. Our God
>> our God shows the greatness. But
>> I I got I got you.
>> I don't know. Look, you said when you
put God in a human form, that's a sign
of weakness. If you think about it, all
the followers listening here, that's a
sign of weakness.
>> You're still you're still missing it.
You're still missing the point.
So when we talk about what Jesus said
about God and Moses and David and the
others, Jesus said that God so loved the
world that he sent his only begotten son
into the world to save it. Jesus is
teaching that God the father has a
begotten son. That is a core that is a
core difference between the God of the
Bible and the God of Islam who does not
beget and has no children in any way,
shape or form. You understand? Do you
realize? Yeah. But do you realize that
Paul is the one?
>> This has nothing to do with Paul. That's
Jesus.
>> No. No. But no, no. You know that Paul,
he he came in and he said that uh he he
he mentioned about the trinity. He made
it.
>> This is you're not you're deal you're
not dealing with with Paul. We're
dealing with what Jesus said. We're
dealing with what Jesus said.
>> We're dealing with Jesus. Okay. In John
I'm quoting from the Bible, right,
everybody? In John 17:3, it says that
Can I pull it up because I don't have it
on my phone. where it says that you're
the only true God.
>> Who's the who who's the father is the
only true God, right? The father.
>> Yeah. The father is the only true God
and whom Jesus
>> is is that Allah is Allah the father.
>> I mean yeah is the one true God. Yeah.
>> Just just to be clear you just said that
Allah is the father.
>> That's how you guys refer. But I don't
>> it's not it's not how we refer. That's
what Jesus says that the true God is the
father. Is Allah the father? Allah has a
son.
>> Allah doesn't have a son. Allah is not a
father. But Allah is the true. So then
then he's not the true God according to
Jesus. According to Jesus, the true God
is the father. If Allah is not the
father, then he's not talking about
Allah.
>> But but the father isn't it's just a
reference by Christians.
>> It's not a reference by Christians. Who
I'm sorry. I'm sorry, brother. Who Who
are you quoting in John 17? Who are you
quoting?
>> I'm quoting Jesus. When
>> Okay, so stop bringing up Christians.
Don't bring up Christians. Don't bring
up Paul. Stick with Jesus. Jesus just
said that the only true God is the
father. Is Allah the father
>> according to your reference? Yeah.
>> According to what you referred to this,
I didn't reference this. You brought
this up. According to what you according
to what you referenced, is all is Allah
the father.
>> If I say yes, I'm not even committing
sherk, bro.
>> Oh yeah, you are. If you say yes, you're
committing sh because you're saying that
Allah has associated a partner with him
by having a son.
>> But I didn't say that Allah is a father
of father. Literally, that's a metaphor.
Is he a father at all according to the
Quran? Is he a father at all?
>> He's not a father at all because he's
not my life.
>> So it doesn't matter. So he's not a
father at all. So is Allah when Jesus
says that the one true God is the
father, is he talking about Allah?
>> He is talking about Allah. Of course.
>> It's just you guys have different
reference, bro. That's it.
>> All right. Take care of yourself, bro.
>> All right, man. School.